>> GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
CELEBRATING BOXING DAY, WHICH IS
REST FROM POLITICS, BUT IT HAS
NOT TAKEN LONG FOR THINGS TO GET
BACK IN FULL SWING THIS MORNING,
MOTIVATED BY HIS STORY HE SAW
HERE ON FOX, PRESIDENT TRUMP
LASHED OUT AGAINST THE FBI OVER
THE INFAMOUS SALACIOUS TRUMP
DOSSIER, THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
"WOW, DOSSIE EIGHT BOGUS,
CLINTON FUNDED DOSSIER, FBI
CANNOT AFTER ALL THIS TIME
VERIFIED CLAIMS IN THE DOSSIER
OF RUSSIAN-TRUMP COLLUSION, FBI
TAINTED."
AND THEY USE THIS CROOKED
HILLARY PILE OF GARBAGE AS THE
BASIS OF GOING AFTER THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
REGIONAL CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR FOR
BARACK OBAMA'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, ROBIN, THIS COOKED UP
IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS, AND THE
FBI HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATING FOR
A YEAR AND A HALF AND HAVE BEEN
CALLED -- DID GET ON THE PLANE
TO RUSSIA AT SOME POINT,
OTHERWISE AFTER 18 MONTHS, ALL
ON COOPERATED, DO YOU THINK THAT
THE FBI SHOULD TAKE ANOTHER TWO
YEARS, THREE YEARS, FOUR YEARS,
FIVE?
>> I SURE HOPE NOT, MARK, THE
TAXPAYERS ARE FUNDING THE
FBI HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF -- ANYTHING THAT
IS PRESENTED AS EVIDENCE, LEAVE
NO STONE UNTURNED, THAT INCLUDES
A GOD DOSSIER.
SO MUCH IS UNTRUE, THE VERACITY
THAT THEY SAY SHOULD BE
QUESTIONED JUST LIKE ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL THEY HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE LEAD AND THEY HAVE
DONE THEIR DUE DILIGENCE AND IT
IS TURNING OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.
THAT'S WHY HILLARY CLINTON DID
CANDIDATE WHO INITIALLY FUNDED
THE DOSSIER DID NOT USE IT AND
EVENTUALLY SOLD IT TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Mark: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
THERE IS A BIT OF OPPO RESEARCH
LED THE PEOPLE WHO PAID FOR IT
DID NOT BOTHER USING, BUT HAS
SOMEHOW JUSTIFIED AN 18 MONTH
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
IF WE FLIP THIS AROUND, SAY THE
G.O.P. HAD FOUND SOME FRENCH SPY
INSTEAD OF AN AM I SIX GUY TO
COME UP WITH THE SALACIOUS
DOSSIER SAYING THAT TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE IS UP TO'S
FOR 18 MONTHS?
>> NO, I WOULD NOT, BUT LIKE I
SAID, THEY ARE DOING THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE LEAVING NO STONE
UNTURNED, BUT I WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT WHAT LED TO THIS, THE
FIRING OF DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
UNCEREMONIOUSLY.
AND THERE WERE MULTIPLE
INSTANCES WHERE THEY WERE TRYING
TO HACK INTO VOTING SYSTEMS IN
SEVERAL STATES.
IT WAS NOT JUST THE DOSSIER AS
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF TRIED TO
ALLUDE TO THIS MORNING.
>> Mark: THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR LONGER, IT PREDATES THE
ELECTION, SO WHY WOULD THE
RUSSIANS BE TRYING TO HACK INTO
A VOTING MACHINE IN IOWA IN JUNE
OF 2016?
>> MARK, BECAUSE I HAVE AN
AGENDA TO FULFILL, DISRUPTING
OUR WAY OF DEMOCRACY SUITS THEIR
AGENDA.
RUSSIA IS OUR ADVERSARY, THEY
ARE NOT LOOKING OUT FOR OUR BEST
INTERESTS.
>> Mark: WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THE ONLY THING THAT ANY
CONCRETE THAT ANYONE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO FIND IS THAT PUTIN PAID
FOR 100 GRAMS WORTH OF FACEBOOK
ADS.
I NEVER KNEW, SPEAKING OF
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT EVEN ELIGIBLE
TO RUN, I DID NOT KNOW THAT YOU
COULD STEAL AN ELECTION FOR
100,000 IN FACEBOOK ADS WHEN
YOUR CANDIDATE, MRS. CLINTON
SPENT TWO-THIRDS OF A BILLION,
YOU SPEND TWO-THIRDS OF A
BILLION, BUT SOMEBODY BUYS 100
GRAND A FACEBOOK ADS, AND
SAMPLES THE ELECTION AWAY, IS
THAT INTERFERING?
>> NO, LIKE I SAID, I THINK THE
REAL PROBLEM IS WHEN WE FOUND
EVIDENCE THAT THEY TRIED TO
ACTUALLY AFFECT TO THE VOTING
MACHINES IN THOSE STATES, THAT
WE SHOULD ALL DO THAT.
WE SHOULD ALL WANT THE FBI TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR WAY OF
DEMOCRACY IS PROTECTED AND
DEFENDED.
THEY HAVE AN OATH TO DEFEND AND
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTION AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT AN ENEMY OF
THE STATE BY COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIA.
>> Mark: TAKING YOUR LINE THAT
RUSSIA IS A GEOPOLITICAL
STRATEGIC ENEMY OF THE
UNITED STATES, THEY MANAGED TO
GET THE ELECTION STEALING
RACKETS, WHATEVER IT IS, HACKING
INTO VOTING MACHINES IN
BEEN INVESTIGATING THIS NOW FOR
18 MONTHS, WHY CAN'T THE FBI
WRAPPED UP AN INVESTIGATION INTO
AN ELECTION CAMPAIGN AND LESS
THAN THE TWO YEAR PERIOD BETWEEN
ELECTIONS?
>> MARK, WE ARE NOT PRIVY TO
THAT INFORMATION JUST LIKE WE
WERE NOT PRIVY TO ALL OF THE
INFORMATION INTO BILL CLINTON
AND WATERGATE WHICH ENDED UP
BIRTHING THE MONICA LEWINSKY
SCANDAL, WE DO NOT HAVE ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION.
SO IT IS IMPOSSIBLE AND
PREPOSTEROUS FOR US TO SPECULATE
ON WHY IT IS TAKING THIS LONG.
THEY ARE DOING THEIR JOBS.
THEY ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS DOING
THEIR JOBS.
AND THEY ARE BECOMING -- THEY
ARE UNDER ATTACK ON THE DAILY BY
DONALD TRUMP WHO I THINK IS
DOING A PSI OP CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
HE KNOWS THAT THERE IS MORE
INFORMATION, AND HE WANTS TO
PLANT A SEED OF DOUBT IN THE
PUBLIC.
THAT IS REPREHENSIBLE.
>> Mark: WELL, ROBIN,
THANK YOU FOR FRAMING IT AS A
SIAL UP CAMPAIGN, IF YOU ARE
TARGETED BY THE FBI I AM NOT
SURE THAT YOU NEED PSI OPS AND
PROTESTING THAT AGAINST IT.
IF THE OF JUDICIAL WATCH, TOM,
ROBIN WAS RATHER COY ABOUT THAT,
BUT THIS TOTALLY WORTHLESS
DOSSIER HAS HAD AN INCREDIBLE
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU C
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU N
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU O
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU I
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU E
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU A
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU S
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU E
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU T
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU R
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU U
LIFE, IT IS LIKE A ZOMBIE, YOU H
THIS THING THAT THEY COOKED UP
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, IT IS RUNNING
AROUND LIKE A MECHANICAL HARE
ACROSS TOWN.
>> ACCORDING TO THE REPORTING ON
THE TESTIMONY OF ANDREW
McCABE, THE NUMBER TWO AT THE
FBI, THEY COULD NOT CONFIRM
ANYTHING, HE REFERS TO CONFIRM
AWAY FROM CARTER PAGE CAMPAIGN
ADVISER TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
THEY HAVE TRAVELED TO RUSSIA.
CONFIRM, BUT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CONFIRM THAT THE AUTHORS OF
THE TRUMP DOSSIER WERE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN VENDORS, AND THEY WERE
WORKING WITH THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE OBAMA FBI AND
THE FBI OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS THE
LEADERSHIP THERE WAS VEHEMENTLY
ANTI-TRUMP AS HAS NOW BEEN
EVIDENCED, AND THEY LAUNDERED
THIS CAMPAIGN DOCUMENT INTO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND IT MAY
HAVE BEEN USED TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT STILL MAY BE BEING USED BY
ROBERT MUELLER.
ETHICAL CONCERN, BECAUSE OF
WHERE IT CAME FROM.
>> Mark: NO, I AGREE WITH YOU
ON THAT TARP, IT IS A LITTLE BIT
MacGUFFIN, USED AS THEIR
PRETEXT TO SET THE GAME AFOOT.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT HAD NO VALUE,
IT IS ALL PRO RESEARCH TO
HILLARY CLINTON, BUT IT HAD
VALUE TO THE GOVERNMENT, THE
OUTGOING GOVERNMENT AND GETTING
THEM INTO A POSITION WHERE THEY
COULD SURVEY ALL THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THAT IS THE CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> IT GETS EVEN WORSE FOR
MRS. CLINTON, SHE USED HER LAW
DOSSIER EFFORT WHO WENT,
SUPPOSEDLY TO TALK TO
INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE AND -- YOU
HAD THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN SENDING
PEOPLE TO RUSSIA TO FIND OUT
INVESTIGATION ON
COLLUSION, AND THIS IS A
ANTI-TRUMP VERSE, JAMES COMEY
OBVIOUSLY DID NOT LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND LEAKED
INFORMATION TO GET THE
FOUND OUT THAT THE TOP FBI AGENT
IN TERMS OF COUNTERINTELLIGENCEW
IN TERMS OF COUNTERINTELLIGENCES
IN TERMS OF COUNTERINTELLIGENCEA
NEVER TRUMP, AND THE NUMBER
NUMBER TWO ON HIS TEAM
ATTENDED THE ELECTION NIGHT
PARTY AND WAS SENDING FRIENDLY E